if you had to fight over 10,000 demonic
ghosts what would you do you've been
cursed to Forever attract killers from
the spirit world and the only way to be
save will be to team up go on countless
Spirit hunting missions and slaughter
them all I'm going to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat the army of killer ghosts in
Dark gathering this kid will be forced
to battle spirits and bloodthirsty Gods
within the next 2 weeks katoro here has
been cursed and has spent the last 2
years hiding out from terrifying goats
out to get him finally done being scared
he enters back into the world and wants
to get back into society make friends
and forget about his terrifying problem
he meets up with his childhood friend
after so long and the other person who
got cursed alongside him as well AO but
she tells him that he should try to
enjoy life despite their difficulties
like her and encourages him to take up a
tutoring job to distract him in the
meantime getting his first student he
shows up to this house realizing that
his first client is ao's younger cousin
named yayoi and he can tell that she has
Supernatural powers like him maybe even
more she casually chokes this plushy toy
in front of him and he realizes that she
has trapped a spirit inside of that
thing sweating he tries to start her
lesson but she tells him that she knows
he's just like her and tells him that
they should go hunt some ghosts instead
of study wanting to forget his old life
he says no but she threatens to get him
fired from this job if he doesn't listen
unable to refuse yayoi forces him to
join her and AKO who is way too chill
about this and they go on their first
Haunted Adventure heading to the strange
phone booth yoi gives them the rundown
of this place one haunted Hostess girl
lives there a thief while she was alive
and she stole all of her clients money
and eventually got brutally murdered by
her customers as a result she now haunts
anyone who enters or uses this phone
booth since someone put the phone booth
number online for anyone to call yayoi
realizes that she can't sense any Spirit
but suddenly Koro gets massive chills
however he doesn't know why yayoi
switches to plan B and forces Koro to
make the phone booth ring by calling its
number AO then know notices K's scared
face turned into a smile when he calls
but he doesn't realize it calling the
number the phone booth then starts
ringing and they hear something inside
ask them for help a bloody face appears
on the window and forces the booth door
to open yayoi instantly uses this moment
to throw in a toy doll and that's when
the horror begins everyone watches the
doll inside blow up painting the window
full of blood having seen enough for
today the group then heads back home
there kro gets back to tutoring yayoi
and notices that she is extremely smart
which means she probably isn't crazy
about her love for ghosts either and she
tells him that the ghost they just saw
didn't react until K Toto called it and
wants to know why and he tells her about
his curse that anywhere haunted he goes
to ghosts usually will show up excited
at the possibilities she begs him to
take her on more Ghost Adventures hell
no because he wants to move on with his
life and AKO overhears this and speaks
to him privately telling him that yayoi
recently lost her parents in a car crash
and this is why she wants to go on
adventures to find her missing mother
that got taken away by Spirits before
the accident yayoi's eyes suddenly got
double pupils which caused her to see
other things in her vision it wasn't
until the accident that she realized
that her double vision now allowed her
to see the spirit world and the human
world feeling bad Koro agrees to help
her agreeing to go back out for one more
ghost adventure the next day heading
back out yayoi hands him a doll and says
that this will protect him from any
baddies they meet but yayoi drags him to
the same place as yesterday but this
time with a new plan reaching in the
phone booth the ghost appears at the
window and gives off a horrifying smile
shocking kro as it suddenly drags him in
okay well kro might seem really powerful
he's really stupid I would have taken
out this ghost way more quickly by using
something like the mamut 9.5 Craig dry
climbing rope and some good old common
sense let me explain Koro here can
basically sense and feel various forms
of energy which if we think about it are
all around us for examply when your hair
stands up on end at certain times this
is just one example of your body
reacting in real time to energy radi
ating around it this happens since the
cells in our bodies are specialized to
sense and conduct electrical currents
and sources of neutral energy this plus
if we take into account things like the
multi-dimension theory which is the
possibility that there are other
dimensions out there like the spirit
realm things that we can't see yet it
means that yayoi and Koro here might
actually be able to feel and see sources
of energy coming from things that
science cannot fully explain yet however
despite having access to some really
cool superpowers what these guys just
did now was really stupid if I was him I
would have focused on our winning card
yayoi herself before signing on to this
stupid idea I would have tested out the
limits of her powers first get to know
her figure out what can she do as well
as her mindset it's noted that she's
doing all of this really scary crap to
find her mother which while adorable I
will admit means that she's got an end
goal and we have no way of telling how
much she is willing to risk lose or give
up in order to reach her goal since
compared to her parents we're just a
stranger that has no value to her which
means teaming up with this psycho is
really risky and the fact that we
already saw ghost for the first time and
lived to come back again means that
maybe we should rethink this even if
yayoi was leading the mission despite
being 8 years old it's better to have
improved communication between the team
being catero means that I would have
first taken better safety precautions I
would have come in with some climbing
rope and some kind of harness and then
would have tie the other end to either
Guard railing above the hill here we
know that we attract spirits to wherever
we go and this one is super malicious
therefore it's easy to assume that they
would try to get a some H has anybody
watched a scary ghost movie you know
it's going to happen at the end of the
day remember there's nothing to gain
from this ghost adventure if we had just
walked away right now before we even
walked over there we could have avoided
all of this trapped KERO begins
panicking but sees footsteps approach
him just as he gets choked yayoi then
notices that this ghost is overriding
the protection spell that she gave Koro
making her realize how badly Spirits in
general want him having seen enough she
takes out her weapons and charges in
forcing open the door and she grabs K
too's protection doll and slams it at
the phone booth Spirit cutting off the
phone and disabling it she she assures
Koro that she will always protect him
and she traps the evil ghost in a new
plushy toy my how cute this causes Koro
to freak out and wonders what kind of
freak yayoi really is and later he gets
mad at them for all of the ghost things
but akeko points out that when he called
the phone booth yesterday he didn't
realized that he was smiling and
suggests that he actually secretly likes
all of this ghost hunting deep down but
Koro doesn't believe her and suspects
that while yayoi is good at this ghost
hunting thing she struggles to find
ghost herself and this must mean that
the ghost br is actually hiding from
this little girl the next day Koro heads
to ao's place again thinking today will
be a normal day of tutoring oh that's
funny and wouldn't you know yayoi
blackmails him again into going into
another terrifying Adventure is this guy
an idiot or what anyways AO reveals to
Karo that they're going to his grandma's
Shrine today and she tells yayoi that
since Koro got cursed he regularly gets
exorcisms done by his grandma to
discourage Spirits from finding him and
to help him reintegrate back into
society kro gets surprised urised and
says that he doesn't have an appointment
with her for another few weeks but AO
doesn't care reaching granny greets her
beloved AO but cons sense that yoi can
see ghosts too and keeps a watch on her
while kro goes in to get cleansed
waiting outside yayoi is restless so AKO
shows her a picture of what katra's hand
looks like under his glove that he
always wears seeing all of these nerves
she tells yayoi that these things are a
result of his curse and regly gets cut
off during his exorcism while they chant
Shinto prayers after the Clans kater
goost to the bathroom but runs into
another b-level ghost and Yayo saves him
as usual B whatever his not board kro
begins to feel bad for putting yayoi
through so many dangerous situations and
begins to worry about her safety are you
serious she wants these freaking ghosts
Let the Ghosts have her my gosh
finishing up with the exorcism and
another Ghost Defeated granny ends up
liking yayoi and gives her a gift
heading back home she tells kro that she
wants to show him something in her room
heading up he finds hundreds of creepy
dolls on her shelf including the foam
Booth spared from earlier and this makes
him realize why he always felt a creepy
vibe in this house 24 freaking s y yoi
reveals to him that she keeps the worst
of the worst Spirits trapped in her room
including the spirit that they captured
earlier because she is planning
something big in order to rescue her
mother from Death she goes into detail
about how Spirits actually work when
they possess something they get trapped
in its physical state and that is how
yayoi traps them like in these dolls Koo
gets a little too freaked out but eeko
passing by tells him that they're just
dolls and he should chill out making him
realize that aeko can't sense how much
evil is truly here yayoi reassures him
that no matter what happens she'll keep
him safe and then asks for his
fingernails like a creep the next day
Koro struggles to go back to ao's house
he just wants to move on with his life
but he feels like he owes AO something
for helping him entering her house he
prepares to teach another lesson but
Yayo comes at him saying she desperately
needs his fingernails and he gets
freaked out and prepares to leave but
aeko tries to line the mood suggesting
they go out to another haunted spot what
is with these two they're both freak
anyways however this time around kro
stands his ground and refuses leaving
the house confused yayoi tells AKO
they'll go hunt ghosts without him
telling AO that she thought kro liked
hunting ghosts since he could easily
break his curse if he really wanted to
hearing this AO turns her attention
straight to yayoi asking what she means
and this makes yayoi realize that they
both never knew about any of this and
then has a realization she changes their
plans and says she knows a place they
can go to help katero since he is now
her friend as well and she directs AO on
where to go to karos curse they drive to
this abandoned Temple to locate another
Spirit yayoi mentions that this place is
dedicated to babies that died before
they were born and gives AO the rundown
of what horror to expect they're up
against dozens of unborn babies that
haunt the ground and they're all watched
over by Spirit known as the goddess of
children however yayoi says something
crazy and tells ago that she needs to do
this alone and if she doesn't come back
within an hour ago should run to get
help and somehow she agrees like an
idiot to yayo's Crazy plan and leaves
this little child that thinks she knows
everything alone at this spooky
abandoned Temple like an idiot she's so
freaking stupid she heads in and yayoi
senses that there is more evil in here
than she thought just that she gets
surrounded by countless dead babies and
the goddess herself trying to take out
this spirit this umbilical cord shoots
at her forcing her to get back up and
she almost gets crushed by this giant
statue getting seriously injured and
runs for her life she hides out in the
forest and takes out some ghost hunting
equipment these paper dolls adding a
piece of her hair to them she creates
spiritual decoys of herself that also
fun fact to Grant her extra lives my how
convenient and that's when this evil
Undead baby shows up meanwhile AO Waits
outside but then realizes that it's been
over an hour and rushes off to find Koro
for help spinning me like 5 anime
seconds in the Super Market she tells
him yayoi is in trouble and he wonders
how she found him so easily because it's
a little suspicious but EO says Ah not
important and says Yayo was trying to
fix his curse since she could tell it
was bothering him hating ghost but
feeling guilty he agrees to go help
yayoi back to yayoi she just finishes
trapping a baby ghost into one of her
dolls and threatens the rest about to
kill her that if they touch her she'll
kill her hostage giving her a split
second to run for her life and places
more paper dolls behind her to act as
decoys she gains some distance and hides
back of the ghost Shrine she passed
through earlier getting slowly
surrounded she sees the ghost Army
suddenly head in the opposite direction
nearby kro finally arrives and he
quickly bumps into the terrifying ghost
Army and runs for his life reaching the
shrine he hears yayoi calling out and
quickly lures the baby ghost around the
shrine while he comes up with a really
half-ass plan I would have gotten rid of
this Spirits way better than kro here
just saying by using the art of respect
and by kidnapping real life babies let
me explain at this point we know the
dangers of dealing with spirits and Yaya
and AKO especially have done this a
thousand times as we can tell and this
is why it makes no sense why yayoi
didn't leave a detailed list of the
ghosts they were going up against with
AO before going in fully since she
clearly knew what this ghost was before
going in for little 8-year-old girl
who's obsessed with hunting ghosts she's
not that good at it one of the main
rules of hunting ghost even in real life
is treating Spirits with respect because
the ball is always in their court and
this warm-up Common Sense even applies
to General combat respecting the enemy
means that we will take on more
precautions and plan even more carefully
and expect the enemy to be at least
equal to us in threat if not even more
which clearly yayoi was not doing
because so far she's been acting exactly
like how a little girl would surprise
surprise by running around going into
haunted places without a care in the
world and she didn't even bring any
haunted tools the spirit Here is known
in real life as the protector of the
helpless and while yoi might not have
known that this good spirit turned evil
it's noted that this Spirit once watched
over dead babies so is it in logical to
assume that if we stopped by some
neighbors's house and said hey can we
borrow the kid real quick no oh too bad
okay well maybe we knock him out and
then take the kid anyways maybe we can
use the live screaming baby to distract
or lure the good spirit away from yayoi
just saying it could work running around
the shrine kro circles back and yayoi
knocks over this statue grabbing this
piece of the spirit and she quickly goes
to meet K's hand reaching out pulling in
while they get out of the area into ao's
car and finally somehow Escape later kro
tells Yayo he knows she risked his life
for him and he thanks her and she tells
him that he's become her new good friend
and unlike her family she is now strong
enough to protect everyone she then
takes him to her room and reveals why
she needed his fingernails she needed
them in order to make the possessed
dolls work and she's put a piece of her
physical body inside each doll in doing
this it redirects any attack from coming
to her onto her dolls including any
attacks any doll in here tries to do to
her making her safe from harm and these
dolls her full-on servants and this is
what keeps her an acho safe 24/7 and she
wanted to do the same thing for Karo she
throws the finger of the spirit she
collected earlier into her room and
tells her spirits in here that this
finger is the one that tried to hurt her
and as a result hurt the spirits in here
pissed off at this finger they want to
harm it and yayoi then tells them that
it doesn't have a piece of her insided
which means they can take revenge on
this Spirit without getting hurt
themselves and kro looks in horror at
what's going on only a fraction of its
strength here the spirit inside the
finger realizes it's screwed Yayo then
makes this finger Spirit beg her to
become her servant in order to be
protected from harm from the rest of
these angry spirits but kri interrupts
and finally asks a big question why is
she keeping so many spirits in these
dolls and she reveals her game plan oh
good she is building an army of spirits
that will serve her in order to find and
fight the spirit that took her mother oh
that's uh that's going to work out great
she says she was unable to bring the
whole Spirit back from the shrine today
only a finger but she promises kro that
when she heals up she'll go back there
again and capture the whole thing so
then they can fully remove his curse and
he thanks her and to compensate her he
offers to help her dive deeper oh that's
great into the Ghost Adventures
unofficially while he continues to try
and reintegrate back into society wow
that's going to work out great a few
days later kro starts his first day of
college with two important goals one to
handle his Supernatural Powers better
and two to finally make some new friends
like a normal person and he heads to his
first freshman welcome party of other
students like him wearing clothes AO
picked out for him including this pair
of hip glasses that secretly keep watch
over him he very quickly sucks at making
friends but he meets this nice guy who
tells him his name is nagayama president
of some random Club not important and
asks kro to join them for some more
drinks back at their apartment watching
him yayoi hears something in the audio
saying the words die and thinks
something evil is hiding within this
party after the event kro meets up with
nagayama and gets in his car full of
other students from his Club they give
him some water to sober up and tell them
their place is over a complex tea
building but suddenly katro feels a cold
Supernatural chill he tells these guys
about it and thinks he's just being
silly but nagayama tells him he's into
ghost stuff too and tells him a scary
story about their college there's this
secret unive Club at school where a
group of students pretend to be a normal
Club but secretly recruit members during
the welcome party to join them in
kicking buckets you can say each year
the name of the club gets changed
because well all the members die each
time and the police never know who the
new ring leader running the club is
unless they notice the one name that
appears each year on the welcome party
guest list continuing the club's Legacy
and the name is nagayama Koro finally
sees the evil spirit possessing him and
realizes that he is the ring leader and
that's when he gets super sleepy because
he's been drugged and passes out
meanwhile the girls watch him through
their spy gear my H helpful of them
quickly stop creeping to go rescue him
meanwhile heading there yayoi researches
the apartment KRA went to and finds out
133 deaths have taking place there over
the last few years and suspect that a
train station connecting to the school
and this apartment is how the spirit
possessed a passing by student before
corrupting others to join them yayoi
wonders what this spirit is achieving by
Leading people to their death and thinks
something is up just as they reach the
apartment okay well kro is so screwed
I'm glad I'm not him but anyways I would
have fixed all of this by not focusing
on saving kro and rely on this
building's already known reputation look
this situation seems unreal this event
is actually directly based on a real
life event in history known as the
Takashi madaria house complex which was
a large area of buildings that were
built in the 1970s that soon became
known around Japan as the place to go to
if you wanted to well kick a bucket if
you know what I mean it got so bad at
one point in the 1980s around one person
jumped every 65 hours equaling to 133
total people in that year alone the
craziest part about this building was
that most of the deaths committed here
didn't come from the people living there
but came from tourists traveling from
other parts of Japan all wanting to just
reach this building back in the and '
80s there weren't many high-rise
buildings and this building was easier
to sneak into than other commercial
office towers and also building codes at
the time didn't have any preventative
measures like fences on rooftops and
once word broke out about this building
and what it could help certain people do
it became the country's go-to place for
this type of thing but the real enemies
in this case is the school KRA goes to
it's noted that each year a new person
creates the same Club as the previous
year so the cops never know who the new
student Mastermind is but even then at
this point these murders of students
would would have classified this as an
epidemic which means that the school and
police should have noticed each year
they saw new student show up the exact
same name this building at this point in
time would have been on police and the
school's radar it means that the school
by now would have likely wanted to
prevent another disaster from ruining
its reputation in general school safety
is a very high concern in most countries
due to the concentration of vulnerable
youths which is why such systems like
the blue light system are common within
these areas to offer students much more
ways to call for help by us calling the
cops for help or fire department or
something say there was a fire shooting
at a housing complex it would have meant
that the First Responders would have
likely reached their first and would
have given AO and yayoi more time to
spare which would have allowed the
police to focus on saving the other
students and possibly kro while AO and
yayoi worked on taking down the
dangerous Spirit reging the apartment
yayoi climbs out the walls busting in
and saving Koro just in time and stuffs
sacred gold flak sake and nagayama
making him instantly cough out the
spirit but something is off and he's
still angry yoi realizes that this man
was already evil before before the spe
possessed him and she quickly ties up
the bad man while saving the rest of the
students before they die and they
managed to escape before the police show
up while yayoi captures yet another
spirit for her ghost Army on the way
back kro gets bummed out on how he's
failed to make friends once again and
will never go back to a normal life
yayoi tells him that he's better off
learning how to deal with situations
involving ghosts since he'll always run
into them and he must learn how to
protect the ones he loves and not be a
wuss ooh shots fired she offers to train
him and then he has a realization asks
them how they knew where he was but
fortunately yayoi covers AKO stalker
butt by saying they found him with their
womanly intuition a few days later they
go on a camping trip to relax after all
the ghosty missions yayoi asks kro if
he's made up his mind about joining her
official ghost hunting Squad but he's
unsure if he wants to relive his old
life dealing with ghosts just to stop
his curse but AO later convinces him to
join as a nerdy researcher she reveals
that she's been tracking down everything
that has happened to them so far and she
believes everything happens for a reason
and this is why she she continues to
deal with ghosts despite what happened
to them she suggests that they should
work together from now on and to not
split apart and just then AOS someone
fall off a bridge in the distance but
KRA doesn't sense anything and thinks
well she's just probably tired they then
head to bed however later KRA wakes up
to the sound of aeko sleepwalking
towards the bridge where the spirit was
spotted hearing the ghost call out to
her yayoi realizes that this is a
special kind of spirit that uses mind
control to make people jump off of
bridges not technically possessing aeko
they can't stop the spirit until they
find out its actual location and having
a crazy plan yayoi says they must guide
AO to the bridge so they can find the
spirit controlling her and stop it
otherwise AO will never be free so they
get ready accordingly okay so we're in a
situation where the group of supposed
veteran Ghost Hunters sure as act
like amateurs yet again great look even
if we wanted a break from ghost hunting
life it's insane that they didn't better
prepare for problems to come up during
their camping trip since at least two
out of the three people here attract
ghosts daily Japan is almost 70% covered
in forest and this means aside from from
the obvious forced prone environment
which means maybe bringing things like
binoculars or infrared night vision
cameras that would have been one real
great way to not be at a disadvantage
when traveling through an area without
any help that's why them coming out here
as they did was just stupid it'd be like
if you go camping into an area known for
having bears at the very least a sane
person would bring some bare repellent
and also yayoi knew exactly what was
wrong with AO and revealed that ghosts
can also mind control their victims from
another area making them much more of a
threat yayoi could have prepared this in
advance as this type of threat is much
more dead and on top of them them
thinking in the short term like come on
at this point by now you got to equip
yourself with some body cams on your
person so you can begin recording
everything that's happening this way the
footage could have been played back
after each Ghost Hunt then you could
have replayed the events and figured out
what went wrong what went right and what
you could have improved on duh this
would have been a huge benefit to yayoi
and would have made her a better Ghost
Hunter at a much more exponential rate
look at that aren't I smart jeez these
guys are stupid heading to the bridge
yayoi hides while kro guides acho across
it acting as bait sending the location
of one Spirit he radios yayoi about it
using one of her dolls she attacks it
forcing it into a last minute move try
to find a body to possess and aim
straight for katero allowing them to
catch it with a nail protected doll and
they put it in a Spirit prooof bag full
of salt but that's when iGo head
straight for the bridge to jump off
right as one of yayo's dolls gets taken
and thrown onto the floor and just then
other Spirits appear out of nowhere to
rip apart the doll and free the trapped
spirit inside letting yayoi know the
exact amount of spirits in the area
meanwhile Kor reaching for acho falls
off the bridge with her but they get
saved by their rope harness having
planned for all possibilities they
continue to make a run for it while yoy
on the bridge sprays salt onto the dolls
trapping two other spirits in the
crossfire down below kto rushes off with
AO but comes across more spirits in the
distance and realizes they're being
followed and that's when AO starts
freaking out as Koro trips and falls
into the water and that's when Spirits
hiding in the water appear and hold him
down Aiko now possessed pours this
Spirit into his mouth about to get
possessed kro quickly thinks fast and
drinks some sacred sake forcing the
spirit inside of him to exit his body
while he whips out another doll for it
to go into and he traps it inside of his
bag full of salt finally arriving yayoi
comes in and quickly Saves the Day
trapping the remaining angry Spears with
some crazy moves as she gets them to rat
on which one is possessing acho here
capturing that one and finally freeing
AO from possession the next morning AO
wakes up with no memory of what had
happened and thanks kro for saving him
then they both admit their love for each
other and he promises he'll always save
her all hell cute and will end the curse
and will help start their lives soon
with a clean slate and as no idea that
aeko's evil plans of using the curse to
make them be together is secretly
working yeah she's actually low-key a
very high key psychopat great later
yayoi informs kro that seeing groups of
spirits together almost never happens
due to their nature Spirits almost
always consume each other to gain more
energy and to stay in the Living World
longer very much so like complex
building seat great video go check it
out and mentions that they only group
together occasionally if they don't know
they are dead are tied to a certain
location or are grouping together from a
bigger threat in the area yayoi wants
kro to know that it is possible that the
spirit who took her mother is closer
than they think known as the Spectre of
death this ghost has insane power levels
one that they must prepare for and she
thanks Kell for helping her find more
Spirits in one week than she has in
months and this has allowed her to build
her spirit army faster than she thought
possible she then crafts him a spirit
conduit which is basically an enchanted
necklace that will use his powers to
help guide them to more Spirits allowing
them to build their Spirit Army even
faster finishing up the day he heads
back home but gets a call from his
school saying that they have a new
student for him to tutor one that will
change everything the next day he meets
up with a new person but notices her
strange eyes he thinks they're contacts
and sees this clumsy girl with the worst
luck named I Cameo a waitress suddenly
spills a drink on her but kro notices a
pair of footprints on the floor next to
her I knows what he's looking at and
realizes that he can see ghost too she
begs him to help her saying she's never
been possessed but ghosts have always
been around her for years and bad things
happen to the people around her as a
result including the recent death of her
brother she thinks his ghost is the one
protecting her right now from the other
Spirits 24/7 because of this he can't
rest in peace she asks kro to help her
fix this problem so her brother can
finally go to heaven and he decides to
take her to yayoi there I thinks she's
just a little girl but yayoi can sense
that I is being followed by two Spirits
one more evil than she's ever seen
before she quickly sets up a half-ass
ritual great and traps the evil spirit
following I solving her problems she
takes a strand of her from her to put
into a protection doll of hers but
notices that I's eyes have now changed
that night kro has a dream of one Spirit
who tells him that I's brother is the
real threat and he must go save her now
suddenly he gets woken up by yayoi on
the phone she warns him that eyes doll
is currently taking damage meaning
someone is trying to harm I right now
they both rush over to her house dooi
finds the apartment number from kro and
climbs up the building busting in she
sees I's horrifying brother choking her
but for some reason he's forced to stop
as the clock strikes midnight and is now
unable to harm her he tells them that he
was trying to save her from a fate worse
than death and he finally ascends into
heaven a little later I cries about her
bro like a big baby and wonders why he
tried to kill her but kro notices that
he didn't sense anything evil about her
brother which means he must have done it
for a good reason she tells them it
makes no sense since she's only got 4
years left to live anyways yayoi and Koo
look at her and that's when she reveals
a horrifying fate revealing that a few
years ago a god fell in love with her
and decided to take her away when she
turns 20 Koro notices The Same Spirit he
talked to earlier in his dreams in this
family picture of I and her brother he
tells Yayo who doesn't see it she then
refocuses her powers causing her to see
the spirit in the picture too she thinks
kro saw it first because of his family
ties to his Shrine and just then she
notices eyes pupils turned back into
star shapes and suspect that the spear
they caught from I earlier has just
escaped from her room kro mentions he
thought her eyes were contacts this
whole time but yayoi finally realizes
that they're a brand and this girl has
been marked for sacrifice a normal ghost
wouldn't be able to do this which means
this Spirit of that claimed I must have
the powers of a God and just then they
see more Spirits enter the room around I
yoi suspects that this God's energy must
be leaking through her and this is what
is attracting the spirits she assures a
that the spirits in the room now aren't
strong enough to harm her but more will
come if they don't get out of this ghost
Nest immediately she calls acho to come
to drive them back busting in in seconds
she introduces herself to I and KRA
wonders how can she knew where they were
but Yi covers her but with more sweet
sweet lies about to head out kro quickly
tries to hit the bathroom but runs into
this unknown ghost and he starts
fiddling with his brain stem and kro
stares in shock and realizes thanks to
yayo's protective doll he's still alive
safe from harm no Spirit can hurt him
for now Koro rushes back not wanting to
freak AO and II out he calmly tells
everyone that they should leave heading
out yayoi quietly tells him that she saw
the ghost that he saw and they realize
that AI has one doll protecting her
right now but if Mo show up and try to
attack her this doll will not be enough
rushing out they run into a blocked
staircase forcing them to take the lift
seeing K's ghost show up at the door it
follows them floor by floor down
reaching the bottom they run out but
Spirit hands shoot out at AI getting
deflected by some mysterious force and
it grabs K's leg instead violently
pulling him back yayoi thinks fast and
slides into the lift with him and the
two other girls watch them get swallowed
hold now stuck inside these two they get
set down to an unknown basement not
registered to any floor the door opens
up to the spirit from earlier eating
unknown brain stems right in front of
them Yo ects this is too much effort
just to kill them and the ghost likely
wants something from them and that's
when other ghost appear from behind them
and the ghost outside rips on these
brain stems making these kid ghosts
scream in sheer Agony forcing them to
try and push kro out yayoi realizes that
the ghost kids died in the same way
they're about to this evil spirit isn't
letting them rest in the afterlife okay
ker and this group could have escaped if
they were all just aware of two very
important factors one that has to do
with social psychological phenomenons
and survival mechanisms let me explain
we know right now that the ghost wasn't
able to interact with krol's body fully
it means that they still had time to get
out of here and this means there was no
reason to calmly tell them to get out
because in reality if I was him I would
have run back and yelled to have them
get out now because we're all about to
die this would have forced them to act
more quickly cuz why in the world were
they trying to be calm about it the doll
is protecting him they could have moved
a little bit faster they didn't need to
be all sneaky and also escaping the area
and taking the lith was the worst idea
taking the stairs is an obvious choice
even if there was construction but
here's the thing they didn't even bother
to peek and look and see how much
Construction was ahead if there's enough
for them to go around unbelievable they
did something that is based on
psychological survival mechanism known
as catastrophizing which is a tendency
to always assume the worst will happen
basically by predicting for the worst we
can better prepare for the future but
this only works if someone is able to
correctly predict what will happen in
the future and without this this mindset
of thinking has been linked to anxiety
and people who like to feel in control
they say more often to think this way
yayoi in this case is exactly this type
of person it means that her second in
command kro should have known better and
forced his team to at least check out
the stair case rout before retreating to
the lift my gosh they're stupid about to
get pushed out yayoi quickly takes a
plushy Spirit to hand to Koro protecting
him momentarily while she heads out to
attack the evil spirit solo darting
around at lightning speed she distracts
this spirit and drops a rope on its leg
kroa finally gets what's going on and
tugs on the Rope hard trapping him to
the floor yoi then tells this evil ghost
that since it tried to attack them but
attacked one of her dolls the spirit
inside the doll is now super pissed the
trapped spirit inside of the doll begins
violently attacking this brain D ghost
into the lift and it quickly gets eaten
weakening its powers allowing yayoi and
kro to escape from this Dimension
heading back to the ground floor yayoi
then decides to use this brain stem
ghost to help AI with her ghost problem
creating some sort of a messed up ghost
scarecrow to scare away other Spirits
while the ghost children get their
revenge on it for eternity H how poetic
yayoi notes that she still needs to do
some Voodoo stuff before ice house is
truly safe so they head back to her
house and they open her door to see her
Shrine full of spirits violently
destroyed everyone's eyes goes wide and
yayoi knows I Spirit God did this and
it's more powerful than they thought
suddenly I passes up behind them and her
spirit shows up and smiles it tells them
it's not even at full strength yet but
none of yayoi spirits could defeat it
yayoi smiles and says that all the
spirits here are just preschoolers and
her graduate Spirits are somewhere else
and she doesn't even need them to kick
its ass the god dares them to try and
warns Yayo that it will soon capture her
and kill her in the most violent way
possible once it reaches full strength
of course and that's when the group
notices all the dolls in her room begin
to violently VI making Yi realize that
even her evil spirits are aching to kill
this God badly and she thinks if they
all team up her ragtag group of Misfits
will be able to defeat him and save the
world but what did you think about the
video what would you do different don't
forget to like subscribe and leave a
comment down below and as always don't
forget to check out our how toe playlist